[Music]
foreign
and I'm Charlotte gelfand but I'm super
excited to be introducing a workshop
that we will be teaching at posit.com
2023 steal like an artist creative
coding and r
so there's many reasons why you should
take our Workshop but we're limited to
three
um I'll say the first reason is because
it allows you to learn about creative
coding and so broadly creative coding is
when you use computer programming for
artistic expression and both Sharla and
I are data analysts and visual artists
specifically genre of artists and part
of the reason why we are both is because
we were able to leverage our background
in our
to create Arts there's a lot of overlap
in the skills for both and in this
Workshop we will show you how you can
like take your data transformation and
your data manipulation skills and your
data visualization skills and creates
really great art we're taking an
inspiration first approach to this
Workshop starting by recreating existing
works if if you feel nervous or
intimidated or like you don't quite put
the creative and creative coding this is
a really good place to get started
without already having an idea once
you've recreated existing piece
you'll have the activation energy to
remix and reinterpret them and
eventually develop ideas and a style of
your own
finally by joining this Workshop you'll
become part of the Artistry community at
large a group of people who make art
using R Artistry you can get it
have very different styles and tastes
but we're constantly talking and
collaborating when it comes to making
art with art making art with a community
or with friends is way more satisfying
than doing it on your own and way more
encouraging to keep going we're so
excited for this workshop and we can't
wait to see you in Chicago bye
[Music]